Ashida so deal Sookie me fellow ready by
then
welcome everyone this catheter for
little red you YouTube's favorite show T
series is losing so hard I bet I bet
teaser is thinking oh we beat him yeah
we're gonna laugh at some clips here
today but will you accept this challenge
please it will be my last video Jesus
Christ
hurry up hurry up come on come on I feel
like this is exactly how I would react
if someone this this to me sometimes
when people just wake me up at night I
just start screaming because I don't
know what's happening it's my body
adjusting to the concept of
consciousness it just doesn't want to
deal with it he just wanted to die oh
yeah you know if somebody in the house
oh yeah I reckon I want kids just to
troll them like this that's that's just
beautiful
I feel like that's the only good thing
about kids is they control the living
hell out of them look at my bar
look at that bar it is full it got
recharged from that [ __ ] dawg
how about your life how's your life to
going no one cares
literally no one cares Vader is waiting
around
anywhere to scare me cuz all freaked out
[Music]
was that it actually in an anime oh this
is a person yeah it's a persona you'll
never see him tell perfect dance let's
show it synchronize oh god what's
happening see all right what is he doing
hey stop make a joke tell me something
you don't I'll be okay
when t-series beats PewDiePie they're
never saving don't get my taser fake ah
what's happening - Pikachu looks like
it's trying to eat himself
let's pick at you on a bad thing we'll
get those it's alright
Oh your mom took my corporal kit looks
like GoPro get it lagging you ragequit
it ran away oh my god what oh god yeah
it's pretty sexy what can I say why am I
watching this I have a lot of questions
right now there's dolphins get the N
word pads because that's not okay for
dolphins to do that they're not black
all your fish like I don't get it guys
that's what they're trading it's a
hamster again everyone has to do
something for the hundredth time oh why
is no one made a pewdiepie version of
this meme it's so beautiful please have
you smashed like yet someone actually
spent time printing out and cutting out
this is what I'm saying for so long
memes were created just to halt the
progression of mankind
there's no way anyone would spend time
doing this back in the day no one
thought to themselves hey you know what
would be funny if I print out a bunch of
faces or Michael Jackson and put them on
stickman figures no one thought about
that in the medieval ages no one thought
about that when we were during a toga
new game around
alright a booga dooga doing you see what
I'm saying here you see what I'm saying
humanity has reached its peak
[Music]
saltador hey oh yeah cool no particular
car
years and you cannot do in its Gazeta
could no car scuzz konoka terminal
machinery is that the actual I haven't
even watched Jojo and I got the
reference why have I not watched Jojo is
clearly everything I ever won from an
anime worse meme obscene
Jesus Christ not even trying I did
laughs I didn't laugh if I laugh then
the health bar would still be intact so
point proven liberals really good oh my
god it's me Jesus Christ see this is the
kind of enthusiasm I expect when I asked
for a freaking bro fish not today you
have not deserved it then you know very
well what you did wrong if you think I'm
angry now just wait until I'm angry when
T series past well you know that I'm
swaggin you should go with beer Osama
bin Laden
[Music]
I was his heartfelt I felt thank god
damn I felt they hey bring you know that
I'm swaggin you should go with beer
Osama bin let's move on before it gets
to mother tanks
she got waves beldo fing got waves but
it's not even weighs it weights out of
him now
dammit this meme has always been this
bad why is no one given me waves that's
why I'm angry right now what all this is
trauma I will call my mama
that's a beautiful man hi mama oh hang
up on my mama hang up on my mom I've
been sad mama I appreciate you Christ
you should go to therapy man I don't
really know the details but every single
day she dog like a month I don't
understand that was a great Clayton much
tank well done good thing I have a
little zip but don't eat it out of the
dark kids only I can do it because I
have this monster jet all right which is
really questionable at this point that
was legit I like that
good aesthetic sometimes I just forget
I'm recording a video and there's a
certain level of professionalism that
needs to be involved I am sorry all
right
enough playing around I see my health
bar and I realize it's time for me to
yeah no more laughing let's freakin do
this
[Music]
whoo that was hard that was hard
god dammit just doing of some review for
my test just remember one way to read
faster is is to read faster damn that's
some thousand IQ [ __ ] faster or defeat
them found a brother no one translate if
you're Swedish do not translate like do
not do it it's not worth it it's gonna
be bathe major chaos you to shut down
stock go to zero
next clip everyone I want every gun we
have to fire on that man that's CGI Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's pretty good Wolford will know
blades oh he got a blade he's got it
what for nothing it's just wrong he's
gone into stage two the Lord behind why
he has that blade it's red why do you
never do epic stuff like that huh
all you do is freaking sleep what are
you gonna do jump off a bridge like
sleeping and what are you gonna do let's
watch the last clip together like a real
family
I locked it down god damn it
okay everyone that was another episode
of what am i recording your life you
lose that's right everyone
smash like very silently on the video
cuz you sleeping see you guys next week
okay you want to say anything
well that's racist you can't say that
you want pyramids we got him oh you're
into castles huh we got you covered baby
you want some bets easy we got it all
this game is still relevant god damn it
[Music]